tomémonos algunas divisiones de
fracciones y voy a empezar esta vez con
menos 5 sextos menos 5 sextos ok ya esto
lo voy a dividir entre tres cuartos a
esto lo voy a dividir entre tres cuartos
pero ahora en varios de los vídeos que
hemos visto actualmente hemos dicho que
cuando nosotros tenemos una fracción y
la dividimos entre otra fracción
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es multiplicar por el recíproco de la
fracción que está dividiendo y el
recíproco o el inverso de tres cuartos
el inverso multiplicativo es pasar el
numerador al denominador y el
denominador el numerador así que menos 5
sextos lo voy a dejar del cual menos 5
sextos ya esto en lugar de pensar en
tomarme la división entre una fracción
voy a multiplicar voy a multiplicar por
el recíproco o el inverso de tres
cuartos que quedamos que es 44
paso el 4 para arriba y el 3 para abajo
los inviernos ok y esto es exactamente
lo mismo y lo hemos visto en varias
ocasiones cuando nosotros nos tomamos la
multiplicación de fracciones esto es lo
mismo que tomarme la multiplicación de
los de arriba entre la multiplicación de
los de abajo así que déjame poner aquí
mi división me voy a tomar ahora menos 5
por 4 menos 5 ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar déjenme cambiar de color lo
voy a multiplicar por 4 y todo esto hay
que dividirlo entre 6 por 3
todo esto voy a dividirlo entre 6 por 4
1 por 3 por este 3 de aquí por 3 y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo a tomarme
la multiplicación de los dos de arriba
entre la multiplicación de los de abajo
y dice menos por más me va a dar menos y
déjenme poner un color neutro para que
veas que ya llegamos al resultado aquí
voy a tener menos 5 por 4 es 20
y esto / y esto dividido a su vez entre
6 por 3 lo cual es 18 ahora si te das
cuenta esta fracción de aquí se puede
simplificar un poco y se puede
simplificar un poco porque tanto la
parte de arriba como la de abajo tienen
mitad así que vamos a simplificar esta
fracción para que no nos queden una
fracción muy grande y para esto lo que
voy a hacer es dividir la parte de
arriba entre 2 la parte de arriba entre
2 y si quiero que la fracción se
mantenga también voy a hacer lo mismo en
la parte de abajo voy a dividir tanto
arriba como abajo entre 2 para que me
queden la misma fracción ahora date
cuenta que me tomé esta división entre 2
porque tanto el menos 20 como el 18
tienen mitad pero no sólo eso tenemos la
suerte de que el 2 es el máximo común
divisor entre 20 y 18 y entonces me va a
quedar que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que menos 20 entre 2 lo cual es menos 10
menos 10 ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
18 entre 2 lo cual es 9
entre 9 por lo tanto el resultado de al
menos 5 sextos entre 3 cuartos es menos
10 novenos y date cuenta que esta
expresión aquí ya no se puede
simplificar más tanto 9 como 10 no
tienen factores en común ahora lo
importante de todo este ejercicio lo que
quiero que veas es que nosotros
empezamos con una fracción negativa y la
dividimos entre una fracción positiva y
llegamos a una respuesta la cual es una
fracción negativa dicho de otra manera
lo podrás pensar como que menos entre
más es lo mismo que menos o tal vez
podrás darte cuenta que cuando una de
las dos fracciones es negativa entonces
nuestro resultado va a ser negativo
cualquiera de todas estas formas en la
que tú quieras pensar la respuesta es
correcta pero vamos a ver un siguiente
ejemplo qué te parece si ahora empiezo
con menos 4 me voy a tomar aquí al menos
4 ya esto lo voy a dividir me voy a
tomar este de aquí
lo voy a dividir entre un medio al menos
4 lo voy a dividir entre menos un medio
que entre un medio negativo y bueno
utilizando todo lo que nosotros ya
sabemos esto va a ser igual y en lugar
de dividir entre una fracción recuerda
que es lo mismo que tomar 2 la
multiplicación por su inverso es decir
por el inverso multiplicativo de menos
un medio en menos 4 no le pasa nada así
que lo voy a poner tal cual aquí esto va
a ser menos 4 y bueno recuerda que al
menos 4 su mismo que menos 4 sobre 1 lo
voy a poner mejor así para que podamos
multiplicarlo por la fracción que voy a
tener a la derecha menos 4 sobre 1 es lo
mismo que menos 4 ya esto lo voy a
multiplicar lo voy a multiplicar por el
inverso multiplicativo o por el
recíproco de menos un medio que es menos
2 sobre 1 recuerda que lo que tenemos
que hacer es pasar el numerador al
denominador y el denominador el
numerador es decir que el 12 va para
arriba y el 1 para abajo ok y entonces
nosotros tenemos esta multiplicación de
aquí que por cierto es una multa
de fracciones menos 4 entre 1 x menos 2
entre 1 así que voy a poner aquí que
vamos a multiplicar dos fracciones y me
va a quedar menos 4 menos 4 que va a
multiplicar a su vez que va a
multiplicar a su vez a menos 2 y bueno
recuerda que este menos 2 sobre 1 es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme menos 2
entre 1 o 2 entre -1 y -2 entre 1 es
exactamente lo mismo donde quieras poner
al menos a mí me gusta más poner este
signo de menos en la parte de arriba
pero es igual si lo pusiera de la parte
de abajo y la parte de arriba la
propiedad negativa entonces me queda a
menos 4 x menos dos lados dos de arriba
entre 11 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por este 1 de aquí por 1 por este 1 de
aquí ok fíjate que conservamos el signo
y todo va bastante bien y esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que yo no me voy a
tomar este color este color para poner
la respuesta esto es menos por menos me
va a dar más
4 x 2 es 8 es decir que menos 4 x menos
2 es 8 positivo esto ya lo sabemos no es
nada nuevo ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre uno por uno lo cual es uno y bueno
a que si no lo podemos quitar inclusive
porque recuerda que los signos positivos
no es necesario ponerlos así que si
nosotros quitamos este signo me queda
simple y sencillamente 8 sobre 1 que por
cierto esto sabemos que es lo mismo que
george ahora lo único que quiero que te
des cuenta es que pasó con esta
multiplicación esta división de
fracciones una fracción negativa entre
otra fracción negativa y bueno es que
recuerda que al final un entero lo
podemos ver como una fracción como menos
4 entre 1 una fracción negativa entre
una fracción negativa me da una fracción
positiva o dicho de otra manera menos
entre menos me da más hoy podemos decir
que cuando nosotros nos tomamos una
división entre dos fracciones con el
mismo signo en este caso negativo
llegamos a una respuesta positiva en
este caso mi respuesta es de menos 4
entre menos un medio
porque positivo